[Music]
i am known by many names
[Music]
and let you whisper
i am pussyboot
holy freakolos
you launch me
[Music]
and the rest of you play double time
hey
hey you want to see something cool
[Music]
gracias you've been great get home
safely good night
you're still here
okay okay one more number i call this
one the legend will never die
[Music]
i have bad news you died
[Music]
doctor
relax i am [ __ ] booze i have night life
and how many times have you died already
uh
i am not really a math guy hold us
do you like aspartame
does this have shellfish in it
a cat always lands on his feet watch
[Music]
watch
watch
and then there was the giant today so
what is that like uh
a four
that makes eight puss what do you wish
to do with your last life when you only
have one life that's what makes it
special
fear me if you dare
goldilocks and the three bears crying
family
you're supposed to be dead
it never fails whenever i team up with
you things go wrong trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you killed that cute no
and with the paws it's all so
cute
am i doing it
stop you're gonna give yourself a
harness
[Music]
you